however it is not the function of
observation to seek to determine this
relation for in any case it is not the
brain qua physical part which stands on
the one side but the brain quad the
being of the self conscious
individuality this latter is a lasting
character and spontaneous conscious
activity exists for itself and within
itself over against this being for and
within itself stay in its actuality and
its existence for another the being for
and within itself is the existence and
the subject which has a being in the
brain this brain is subsumed under the
subject and gets its value only through
its indwelling significance but the
other aspect of self conscious
individuality the aspect of its outer
existence is being quite independent and
subject or qua thing that is a bone the
actualities existence of man is his
skull bone this is how the relationship
and the two sides of this relation are
understood by the consciousness
observing them
there's a lot going on here in paragraph
331 and Hegel is is really working with
two distinct perspectives the
perspective of dialectical phenomenology
and the perspective of the pseudoscience
of phrenology as a mode of physiognomies
that he's laying out here in order to
essentially combat and the question that
we should ask at this point is well what
should observe ation or observing reason
what should it be observing this is
where the two things are going to split
off from each other
and actually in a way think about it
this way phrenology is splitting off
this way getting some things right at
the start and then going in the wrong
direction
dialectical phenomenology of what the
sort of the sort that Hegel is doing is
also going its own way but it's looking
back at what the mistake is that
phrenology is falling into Hegel is
going to say that we can look at the
brain in two different ways he says it's
not the function of observation to seek
to determine this relation what's the
relation the relation between you know
little sub organs of the brain and bumps
or recesses or you know whatever is
going on in the skull so we talked about
in the last paragraphs
he says for in any case it's not the
brain a physical part which stands on
what on the one side but the brain quad
the being of the self conscious
individuality the brain has a double
sided 'no stu it so what Hegel is doing
here let me remind you once again I said
this in a previous video about you know
an earlier paragraph that that we often
frame the problem of consciousness or or
the soul or spirit or whatever we want
to call it the mind in relation to the
brain as if the brain is purely a
physical organ just a bunch of you know
neurons connected up with each other
interacting through a lot
chol impulses and you know interacting
with certain other systems as well
through these chemical interactions and
then we said well okay how do we get
consciousness out of that Hegel doesn't
frame it that way as we've seen he sees
the brain itself as what he's going to
call the indwelling seat of spirit
there's already in a certain way the
brain is beyond what physiologist
imagined the brain to be very similar to
you know as he's talked about the
cadaver the the dead thing is not the
living body and what constitutes the
life in it well that's that's a more
complicated question well maybe come
back to that so he says we've got you
know two ways in which we can look at
the brain the being of self conscious
individuality that's what the brain is
supposed to be doing and in its normal
development whether the brain
understands how that's happening or not
that's what the brain brings into the
world and by doing so the brain is a
mediator it's an organ for spirit and
Hegel says we can look at these two
different frameworks phenomenology is
going to look at this and at this for
analogy is just going to look at this
bottom part so he goes out and he says
this latter self conscious individuality
as a lasting character and spontaneous
conscious activity we've got character
just transliteration of the German
character and then what I've translated
here as self moving and conscious act
Miller has the translation as
spontaneous conscious activity
spontaneous self moving okay
spontaneous makes it sound like it's
just you know popping into existence the
German is actually vegan but moving
itself when before conscious self
conscious and then act hot or tun one or
the other
blank on which one it was but activity
okay activity works for that as well
now remember back to how important the
stress that Hagel laid turned out to be
on the fact that we don't figure out
whether somebody is a certain way if
somebody has a certain character by just
looking at their their skull or looking
at their face or their gates or
something like that but we actually have
to look at the activity at what they do
that's that reveals character that's
that's active whereas this is just sort
of assignment passive as that just
receives something it just is like you
know angles gonna talk about as
actualities and I'll talk about it as an
independent thing so he says if we if
we're thinking about the brain in terms
of what it does as the organ of Spirit
it is you know mediating character it's
representing or you know providing
character and self moving and self
conscious doing that's what the brain
does the brain is this incredibly
complex and reflexive thing I mean
you're thinking about your brain right
now right so what is going on there are
you as it is just a bunch of neurons
firing in there there's like a little
you know tiny little picture however
else we're gonna try to represent it to
ourselves you know about what's going on
with neurons no you're thinking about
your brain right now and Hegel was
writing about his or one's brain two
centuries ago and these linguistic
symbols are reawakening that through the
mediation of you know wonderful
technology and including the technology
of letters in in your brain so there's
more going on at the brain than just the
physical part the wetware considered by
itself the gray matter he says over
against this being over against this
being for and within itself stand its
actuality and its existence for another
these two sides right
we can think of the brain as just that
thing all right that you could hold in
your hands if you took it out of
somebody else's skull can't do that with
your own of course right with no way in
which that that would work but that's
just the its actuality and that's its
existence for another nothing wrong with
that of course right being being
external having existence for another
that's okay that's that's that kind of
being that's that mode well there's more
to the brain the brain is also being for
and within itself closes parentheses
here forensics I'm right that's being
for itself and being in itself within
itself is how we're translating it here
rather than on Zeek in Z there's a
reflexivity that we've been pointing out
to individuality to spirit to the brain
as the organ as we've understood it now
that by which spirit carries out its
activity in the individual human being
spirit also carries out its activity
then society within culture these things
which impinge upon the individual but
we're going to get to that stuff later
in the spirit section and in other parts
of the reason section so we have a huge
difference between these two ways of
looking at the brain he goes on and he
says the being for and within itself is
the essence and the subject which has a
being in the brain this being is
subsumed under the subject and gets its
value only through its indwelling
significance okay what is all that
jargon mean right another way of
thinking about this is that insofar as
we can actually understand what Hegel's
saying with our brains were doing
precisely what he's talking about
insofar as our brains can be a question
for us that's not just a bunch of
neurons firing but something that has
significance we are observing reason as
a mode of spirit understanding itself in
relation to its very corporeality
mediated through that that organ so this
is quite important here isn't it
he says the being is subsumed under the
subject right under the thing which can
act which can act not only on other
things but upon itself
what is the act of the brain well it
does a lot of things at commands right
but it also thinks and it thinks not
just about the external stuff but about
the very being of the person the being
of the individual your brain is your
brain my brain is mine we can't really
do this is sort of science fiction swaps
of taking your brain out of your body
and my brain and swapping him back and
forth or uploading them to a computer
and then you put your download your you
know brain image into me and vice versa
or something like that in part because
it is tied to individuality which is
corporeal so he goes on and he says but
the other aspect of self conscious
individuality the aspect of its outer
existence is being as qua independent
and subject or qua a thing it's an
independent thing this is the brain
understood is that gray mass greyish
pinkish full of all sorts of goopy stuff
inside of your head and this is
something that's also real and he says
it is present as an independent thing
and here's where we're getting to the
perspective of the chronology right he
says it is quad thing that is a bone
what bone the skull the skull that is
reflecting what's
happening in the brain or reflecting
what has developed of the brain or what
the brain has to tell us about itself
not through action not through what a
person actually does but through bumps
through pert Rubens's through little
recesses through all of these sorts of
things but if you think about it really
kind of kind of funny to talk about and
he says so if we adopt this point of
view which Hegel is not endorsing what
is that what is the brain the actuality
and existence of man is his skull bone
the actualities in existence of a person
of an individual is that skull that you
can feel that you can look for bumps
under the hair maybe shave the head so
you can see the bumps a little bit
better a little bit of a digression here
I remember when I went in the army
there's there's a time that happens
where you know you're all recruits and
people come in with all sorts of hair
and then everybody goes to the barber
and it all gets shaved off and suddenly
people look you know very strange not
just because they don't have hair but
you look at some people and you're like
wow that guy's got a funny head other
people you look at night like I doesn't
look too bad bald some people you look
at and they've got big scars and all
sorts of things you're like wow what
happened to you well that's that's
because that's the externality that is
being existence for another I can look
at your head once it's shaved and say
that's a big nut you got there on your
head how'd you get that because you
exist for another that way that's how we
exist in the world a world full of
others and we're reducing as as doing
the phrenology path we're reducing a
person down to their skull down to what
is exhibit a bull we might say so he
says this is how the relationship and
the two sides of this relation are
understood by the consciousness
observing them this is how observation
observing consciousness goes in the
wrong direction in the pseudoscience of
phrenology
observation has now to deal with the
more determinate relation of these
aspects the skullbone does have in
general the significance of being the
immediate actuality of spirit but the
many sidedness of spirit gives its
existence a corresponding variety of
meanings what we have to obtain is the
specific meaning of the particular areas
into which this existence is divided and
we have to see how these areas contain
an indication of that specific meaning
so here in paragraph 332 Hegel is going
to insist that phrenology reveal itself
to us and what it's what it's about
he says observation now has to deal with
the more determinate relation of these
aspects so it's not enough just to say
that there is some sort of causal
relationship here in general between
spirit and the skullbone he does say
that the skull bone can be understood as
the immediate actuality of spirit that's
that's quite all right but that's not
going to be enough right because we have
to get down to the determinacy of it how
was the skull shaped what's going on
with it why is there that bump over
there and not on that side so he says
the skull bone does have in general that
significance of being the immediate
actuallity of spirit but spirit is
many-sided it feels idea and in the
German so there's many sidedness this we
might call it you know plural
potentiality if we want to joke around
in terms of cellular things since we're
talking about you know the organ right
because of spirits many sightedness that
many sightedness has to have it's fine
have its representation its expression
its push and pull you might say in that
skull bone and so Hegel is going to talk
here about particular areas of the skull
bone which particular area is pushed
upon by what aspect of spirit what side
of spirit he says that's what we need to
determine he says what we have to obtain
is the specific meaning of the
particular areas into which this
existence is divided and we have to see
now how these areas contain an
indication
of that specific meaning so how by
looking at the particular regions of the
physical you know outer shell the skull
the the dead thing which is really is
alive - how are we going to figure out
what they correspond to in terms of our
spiritual functions mental functions if
you like our aspects of our personality
how do we parse this out well that is
what phrenology attempted to do and if
you look at some of the artifacts of
phrenology you got to see these maps of
the skull and like what part
corresponding to what part kind of
similar to other things which say like
you know well - every part of the hand
correspond you know different organs or
aspects of the personality right it will
except in this case we're looking at the
skull so it's not like the hand which
does hot stuff I mean your skull does
some things mostly you know keeping your
your brains from falling out but you
know housing the eyeballs and other
things as well that are that are quite
important but here's the point if we're
going to take phrenology seriously and
Hegel is not endorsing phrenology but
he's saying let's take it seriously see
where it goes and then we'll drop the
boom on it then there's got to be some
sort of correspondence between the many
sidedness of spirit and the specific
regions of the skull
the skull bone is not an organ of
activity nor even a speaking movement we
neither commit theft murder and so forth
with the skull bone nor does it in the
least betray such deeds by a change in
countenance so that the skull bone would
become a speaking gesture nor has this
immediate being the value even of a sign
look and gesture tone of voice even a
pillar or post erected on a desert
island directly proclaim that they means
something else than what they simply are
at first sight they at once professed to
be signs since they since they have in
them a peculiarity which points to
something else by the fact that it does
not properly belong to them a variety of
ideas may well occur to us in connection
with a skull like those of Hamlet over
Yorick's skull but the skull bone just
by itself is such an indifferent natural
thing that nothing else is to be is to
be directly seen in it or fancied about
it then simply the bone itself it does
indeed remind us of the brain and it's
specific nature and of skulls of a
different formation but not of a
conscious movement since there is
impressed on it neither a look nor a
gesture nor anything that proclaims
itself to have come from a conscious
action for it is an actuality whose role
it is to exhibit another sort of aspect
of the individuality one that would no
longer be a self reflected but a purely
immediate being
paragraph 333 brings this examination of
the key material of phrenology to to a
clocks and closes off one door which is
that of saying that the skull has some
sort of significance in and of itself as
being what it is in its identity now
notice what Hegel is going to tell us
about and some of this may seem quite
obvious but there's some very important
implications here he says the skull bone
is not an organ of activity right the
skull bone houses the brain the brain is
an organ of activity as a matter of fact
the brain is the organ which is
originating activity he's just called it
in the previous paragraph a self moving
self conscious activity right that of
thinking doesn't mean that we're totally
self conscious and you know the pure
luminosity even decart's coach Ito
wasn't wasn't that but we are conscious
of our self the skull is not conscious
of anything scholars just bone right and
the skull does not engage by itself in
any sort of activity what else doesn't
it do well he says we don't commit theft
or murder or write poetry or make them
you know love or hate people or do
whatever we do with our skull I suppose
you could say if you want a head but
somebody you you certainly do do that
with your skull right good thing because
if you tried to brain but somebody you'd
really mess up your brain but even that
is your brain is deciding to do that
headbutt right the skull by itself is
pure passivity it is actuality but it's
an actuality that's not self moving it
can only be moved and so far as the body
decides to go somewhere and then what's
deciding whether the body's going so the
brain on the brain is the indwelling
seat of spirit so it's really spirit
that that's running the show you know
mediated through the brain which acts
upon the body it's not the skull so that
is
sort of cut off we're always feeler we
can scratch these out I've got this you
know the skull is not any of these
things that we can tabulate up she says
it doesn't in the leaves betray these
deeds by a change of countenance so that
the skull bone would become a speaking
gesture right
it doesn't engage in any sort of
linguistic activity doesn't even do so
by what it provides a shape for the
skull can give you a certain appearance
right I have high cheekbones which I
guess is in many respects a good thing
although you know low cheekbones might
be nice for other things as well right
but that it doesn't affect whether I'm
smiling or whether I'm grimacing or or
whatever I'm doing the skull doesn't
affect that it can condition the way my
smile looks right I mean we may as well
say that the teeth lose their job do I
guess the teeth could be part of the
skull if you want right you know nice
smile you know maybe not so nice of a
smile whatever it's gonna be right angry
face maybe I show my teeth or something
along those lines
the skull is merely a age in which these
things can happen it originates nothing
the skull by itself does not give you
any sort of significant
gesture or look the bear does gesture
right the minute is the look the the
countenance the cast something else has
to be using the skull in order to do
that so the skull considered just by
itself isn't capable of that now I mean
you can do reconstructions the way they
do on these you know discovery shows
where you take the you know skull and
you reconstruct what the face would look
like but that's a dead face that doesn't
have animation to it of course you can
use you know computer programs to make
the face do certain things we've even
got those interesting robots now that
make all sorts of facial gestures but
that's just programming and that's got
to have movement the skull by itself
doesn't move itself it only moves when
it's participating in something which is
more than it that is using it when the
skull is considered solely on its own
account
it doesn't possess these he goes on and
he says something else it doesn't have
the value even of a sign now a sign for
Hegel is in many respects lower than it
would be in value you might say than it
is for other other theorists who work in
the field of what we call semiotics for
semioticians everything is potentially a
sign and signs can be arbitrary or they
can be what we call motivated where
there's some sort of you know meaning
and capsulated in them that isn't just
sort of thrown in there arbitrarily for
Hegel when he uses the word sign he
tends to mean the arbitrariness any
saying look it doesn't even have the
arbitrariness that signs themselves have
that's really getting low on the on the
pole you might say or the the
arrangement of spirit for for Hegel so
you know what are things that give us
you know the aspect of sign well you
know gestures and looks right a gesture
doesn't have an automatic decoding
process for it you know some things this
is why we have to do cultural
sensitivity classes right when somebody
goes from one culture to the next
culture the same gesture might be great
to do in one culture and it means
something horrible and the other culture
that's because there's a kind of
arbitrariness because it is a sign Hegel
talks about tone of voice skull kind of
influences your your voice right it
influences the sonority of your voice
right or your nasally well that's
probably something to do with
more than the skull you know also your
tissues that are surrounding it but your
scholars were there anchored so okay
that but it doesn't affect the tone of
your voice am i talking to you in a nice
way right now because of something
having to do with my skull and now
talking to an aggressive way because of
something to do with make no it has
nothing to do with my skull I originated
that and the I hear in this case it is
the brain and the spirit that's using
that brain as its organ the skull is
just where it's happening skull is you
might say the vehicle that that's
allowing that or the house the structure
around it Hegel even goes so far as to
talk about artifacts he says even a
pillar or post erected on a desert
island directly proclaim that they mean
something else than what they are what
they simply are at first sight so this
is one of the things that's important to
point out that Hegel is kind of
presuming that you understand a sign is
something that doesn't just signify
itself it signifies something else so
let's take this for example
reading right Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit letters or signs they're put
together in larger order sign like the
word Hegel what's that Hegel is it just
referring to those letters no it's
referring to some dead guy who hasn't
been around for a century and a half and
whose picture you see at the start of
every one of these videos and whose
thought is somehow encapsulated in here
and we're talking about today there's a
lot of stuff going on there semiotic lis
in terms of the signs that are happening
there's a whole world of reference or at
least meaning outside of just this thing
here what about the skull there's the
skull of sign in that sense well you
know we put a skull and crossbones on
pirate flags and we have a skull for you
know poison
and people get tattoos of skulls I guess
to make themselves look tough or you
know maybe out of sentimentality I don't
know you know we have different kinds of
skulls we have funny skulls and ugly
skulls and you know okay but that's not
a skull taken just on its own he has
this great example here that you know if
we've never read Hamlet at least we know
about this scene where Hamlet has
Yorick's skull in his hand he's actually
in the graveyard and he says alas poor
Yorick I knew you well right and he's
talking to the skull because Yorick is
dead Yorick is gone the whole of Hamlet
is in in many respects a meditation upon
death and what happens to us in our
corporeality and our spirituality when
we die and so he says a variety of ideas
may well occur to us in connection with
a skull like that of Hamlet over
Europe's but this skull bone just by
itself is such an indifferent natural
thing that nothing else is to be
directly seen in it or fancied about it
then simply the bone itself if we're not
bringing to the skull all sorts of
associations of our own but we're just
looking at the skull itself to figure
out something about human activity human
significance human meaning even the
crazy things people do like put up a
post on it on a desert island Beach
where I can see anything
now Hegel is not using this term
identity here but I think this is a good
term to bring up at this point
what he's saying here is that the skull
just is what it is it's a pure identity
and as a pure identity it doesn't have
any significance he goes on and he tells
us the skull could remind us of other
things it might remind us of the brain
and it's specific nature and of skulls
of a different formation but it cannot
remind us of a conscious movement it can
remind us of the brain
this wet goopy thing with all these
lobes that goes inside of it sort of
like a walnut you know inside of its
shell only a lot you know mess here
let's don't walk that right and a lot
more complicated and more interesting
but it can't tell us anything about what
the brain does this is going to be a big
problem for phrenology if we're just
considering the skull solely on its own
then we don't really have that much to
work with there isn't a meaning to even
be explored let alone exhaust it there
he says there is impressed upon the
skull neither a look nor a gesture nor
anything that proclaims itself to come
from a conscious action for it is an
actuality whose role it is to exhibit
another sort of aspect of the
individuality one that would no longer
be itself reflected but a purely
immediate being when we're reduced to
our skulls and remember in the previous
paragraphs right Hegel has said the
actuality of a human being is their
skull according to phrenology it's a
reduction to pure immediacy it's a
reduction to pure actuality it's a
basement and evacuation of meaning of
consciousness and thereby of
individuality in the human sense skulls
can have individuality as skulls right
because they're this skull as opposed to
that skull but they don't have the sort
of individuality that humans have that
we're supposed to be observing in this
section of observing reason and so
identity is kind of got put that up
there for a play on words we have a sort
of bear identity of the skull with
itself we don't have what we talked
about as our identity as the identity of
a person that lies over here in all of
these sorts of things and and more in of
course spirit
so this is closing off one of the doors
for phrenology it's saying whatever
you're doing there it better not just be
looking at the skull and saying we can
deduce all sorts of things from that
because by itself the skull doesn't tell
us about any of this stuff that we're
really interested in and it doesn't
yield us the identity of the individual
you